hey it's kind of money paper route
beating this whole lot of your thing
check me on the bootleg kill podcast
let's go
who like cab podcast we got a special
guest in here man shout out to homie
kenny money in the building king of mine
what's up welcome
welcome man
paper route empire in the [ __ ]
building how long have you been signed
uh to pre
assigned pre two-year
you know for people who don't know man
like dolph's been kind of
obviously before his passing he was so
passionate about like putting on people
from his city yeah you know what i'm
saying like that was like one of his
major
um
missions um with with paper rock empire
um what was uh what was it about you
that got him on
or got you on his radar rather and a lot
when i was like
when i was young
you know we from the sign area so
that was like
i'm coming up that was the reasoning in
the hood like coming through and
porsches and all the you know i'm saying
whips big boy giant big boy rings like
yeah
i want to do what he doing right there
he turned
so but what what um what were you doing
that that caught his attention
yeah to sign you yeah oh yeah i was
doing
i was making my way towards what he was
doing you know i was shooting my own
videos
booking my own shows just turning up
just turning up doing it dropping music
going crazy yeah
and it and it obviously caught his
attention yeah and i used to call him
for like advice i was scared i want to
know so i'm trying to hit you up hey bro
what this mean what
how much this cause what i need to do
with this like not even sign he was
still giving me all the game he was
giving me so before you even signed him
you had you were able to reach out to
him and get game from him for sure what
do you think like uh is some of the best
advice you ever got from dolph
man
be yourself
like be yourself and keep working the
work gonna talk for you you ain't got to
say much just work everything on show
nah for sure man um
work ethic is i think what does it mean
like we see a lot of people who were
like man a lot of cats ain't even as
talented as some of the people we know
but it's the workout
like don't never let nobody out work you
that's all i used to just work hard 100
percent man um so you finally got your
tapes coming out at midnight i'll take
on that midnight um the long long lived
off project came out which was an uh a
great body of work great dedication to
the homie yeah i put my we put my my
whole tape my table was supposed to drop
like in november but
of course the dog had to come out you
know what i'm saying yeah like great
tape shout out emily choppa 2 he moved
his release date back a week for that
project um yeah that was all right yeah
um
for you like uh
how much of this was you said it was
supposed to come out november how much
of this did you go back and have to like
kind of update after dolph's passing
because i mean that's gotta that's gotta
be a little bit of a few songs yeah cuz
i know a lot most of the songs dog
handpicked you know i'm saying
he was really like hand picking i didn't
want to touch it too much right because
it's still like it's like his hands
running yeah hands on it like not gonna
do so much well of course i had to put
role model on that cause that was from
you know from the heart so i had to put
that on there in a couple more different
ones was that a hard video to shoot the
role model video
it was hard
like
it was hard to do just the thought of it
but
it was i got my phone across though yeah
yeah no dope video um i feel like too it
was ashtray like one of the last records
like like videos dolph did yeah
it was our first well not now that was
our first video
since i've been signed
like the we had a song a couple of years
back i wasn't even signed then we did a
video to it but when i signed someone
was like no i ain't doing the videos
right he always tries to make me stand
on my own i respect it though that's why
i'm good that's dope nah that's dope i
think a lot of people like when they
sign to a bigger artist they kind of
depend on like oh no i'm gonna get all
these songs and all these videos with
that guy he went heaven right it's like
you gotta get it on your own type [ __ ]
yeah i mean that's what glock did you
know what i'm saying for sure um who
else on the project
big moocher
uh glock
and drizzy andre's from chicago jersey
fire yes for sure yeah she's super super
slept on too is she hard what is the
temperament you think right now when it
comes to just the city of memphis it
always feels like i mean you guys like i
said when it comes to hip hop
memphis is on fire for sure but it also
feels like a very divided place in
certain aspects there's you know there's
some artists who are kind of like you
know kind of neutral it seems like but
for the most part it seems like a real
divided place like how is the
temperament in the city right now
there's a lot of pride and a lot of
people feeling like
one person's success
like
is gonna make them not successful like
right like your success don't got [ __ ]
to do with mine exactly like billions of
people in the world pocket watching you
know i'm saying that pocket watching to
get you man we start looking at across
the aisle of what someone else is doing
and you let that make you feel a certain
type of way about what you're doing yeah
that's where you start [ __ ] up and
they'll be hating and loving you at the
same time
that's real yeah so this if it's just
you know they just
they'll they'll start off as fans you
know what i'm saying and
like what you're doing but once they get
to the point to where they'll be using
this motivation but once they get to the
point they feel like they want to be
better than you they think they got to
step on you to be better when it's like
no you just do your thing stay motivated
you ain't got to
be better than the next person to be a
good you 100 percent
like you said be yourself that's some
real [ __ ] yeah that's a real [ __ ] um who
like uh like you coming up
in the city who was like your biggest
influence is just like as far as like
your style rapping and maybe not they
don't even necessarily have to be from
memphis
um
guccifer gucci yeah dog for show
booster for show like you met boosie yet
i ain't met him yet he won't disappoint
you i just i ain't gonna laugh when you
meet him he's gonna be exactly who
you would like hope them to be hey y'all
you know i was listening like my age
folks weren't able to be listening to
the boots i was listening to boost when
i was super young like how young i was
like
there was like a seven-year-old kid
recently who had a birthday party that
was a nba young boy themed so i believe
anything they had like maybe a young boy
[ __ ] tablecloths and plates and [ __ ]
the kid was seven i said what the [ __ ]
is going on
my sister used to play and now she's go
buy the cds from my ace they have this
the you know how boozy to be complaining
like about my cds
like now they hit the boot yeah
hey man i always tell people like when
boozy call himself like the tupac of the
south there's some like real
[ __ ] to that yeah because i lived in
florida when he got out of prison
and
i man
it's different people don't even
understand so so yeah people don't get
it unless like you see it like you gotta
see it like it's like you know being in
la being on the west coast people don't
understand like the
the gravity that like boozy holds in the
south yeah like he is like certain
people was like everything he made
timeless music you could put on booster
right now it's still going to touch
whoever because it's timeless he coming
from the soul from the soul for show
yeah and he's also the like might be the
funniest [ __ ] out of the show in
hip-hop he's a riot he's a crazy he's
hilarious
and he's uncancelable no you can't
cancel it you can't cancel
everybody trying to you can't cancel him
like what do you do man like in your
spare time like what are you into you
play video games you watch netflix you
know when you're not rapping getting
money i just just
i just started being able to have free
time
like to be able to play i'd be playing
the game sometimes call of duty or what
i like call of duty i like guns
i mean i love call of duty i like grand
theft auto 2 now i just started playing
you start doing the uh you know what t
grizzly does on grand theft auto he does
a role playing [ __ ] for real see i ain't
got that deep into it yeah t grizzly is
making like hundreds of thousand dollars
a month on twitch just playing grand
theft auto they've been trying to teach
me about the guy that just get on there
bro get on twitch yeah if you play just
be yourself be funny on twitch while
you're playing video games yeah bro it's
a bag
like we're talking like t grizzly don't
gotta rap no more all he has to do is
play grand theft auto
i know
t you know who t-pain is right yeah bro
t-pain makes playing a guy a stupendous
amount of money
on twitch yes he just plays video games
and he's making
a ridiculous amount of money i just
thought i ain't that good but i just
started playing you don't even got to be
good you just got to go online get on
the webcam set your room up
and you got fans they'll pull up [ __ ]
talk your [ __ ] just be funny smoke yeah
you know they be pulling up on me
yeah
for sure
um where were you when you found out
about uh what happened to dolph
no
i was at the house
in memphis
no
well you obviously not yeah yeah
you know
yeah it's crazy because i was in las
vegas and it's it's wild because i
talked to dolph the monday before he
passed
about i was like talking to him about
glock and glock [ __ ] and he's like yeah
the new glock [ __ ] is crazy like you
need to bring him by the show but i was
actually in vegas
um
doing some empire [ __ ] you know i was
out there with ghazi and uh
and it was it was a man that was a rough
a rough day i could only imagine for you
and just even just the city of memphis
that um
i feel like it broke memphis for a
couple of days man you know um
it's crazy it's it's a tough situation
what about that situation um
what did you learn man from that because
i feel like
when you lose somebody who's so
important to you who's done so much for
you like
you could you know there's there's
always positives to take away from any
situation was there anything maybe you
learned about yourself or
how to move or anything like that
what i learned
mainly from the
one of the things i made sure that i
took from it was just
to take
to to just enjoy the fact that i got to
you know
hands-on deal with a soul like that you
know what i'm saying and just to make
sure like
it's not in vain you know what i'm
saying like
i'm ready to take responsibility to do
whatever got to be done you know what
i'm saying to where he can live through
what i got going on
so his life just made me a better man
all together music wise
family-wise streetwise just made me
realize how important that i need to be
and also just like giving people their
flowers while they're here like you
never know you know during the interview
like
a couple weeks ahead like
he was doing an interview he was
interviewing you know i'm saying he
asked me like
what you see yourself doing in five
years what you want to do bro i'm like
i want to do what you're going to be
like you i tell me his face you know
what i'm saying like
i always tell him like i see like i told
you i always hear the move like bro you
i need to know this i need to know this
like i'm a sponge and you know so i just
feel like all the guys that i did get to
learn all the little he did have for me
i just got to use it and just turn into
a gorilla and just keep the legacy alive
yeah for sure yeah the role model joined
was crazy too man um straight from the
heart i can imagine i can only imagine
um
what what who like now that um
you know paper route empire obviously
you know dolph
ran the whole [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying like i know he had his ear to the
street when it came to picking new
artists for sure he was a great a r a
lot of great artists
and i look at the rla were full of
different variations of those yeah like
for sure nah he's i mean he was an
amazing a r like i think of like you
know just to be an independent boss like
now that um he's going like who's kind
of like
you know is everyone kind of chipping in
to just kind of help keep everybody
doing their part everybody working
harder
everybody each artist standing in the
studio
you know i'm saying our team's working
hard everybody just going
into guerrilla mode like they should be
yeah i mean
they were saying that the um
the suspects that obviously got arrested
were around a little bit were these
people you knew
or that you saw around
no
because the internet be talking you know
what i'm saying about oh look he was in
the picture uh in the background with at
a club and i'm like well they i mean
people would be in the backgrounds of
clubs all the [ __ ] time you know what
i'm saying
no
it's just
ain't much we can say about it at the
moment you know that's fair
it's just
what it is i hope they bury them boys
into the jails what i'm gonna say um
let's lighten things up man so memphis
obviously there's a lot of culture in
the city
shout out to the grizzlies the grizzlies
going crazy right
for sure going crazy going crazy right
now yeah grizzlies might be better than
the warriors now after y'all got blown
out by 40 last night um
but just so much culture in in memphis
man um the barbecue the [ __ ]
ones if someone's never been to memphis
and then they pull up to your city what
are like the two or three things that
they got to do while they're there
i feel like you got to for sure get you
some barbecue
which which barbecue spot though
like what's the spot because you know
there's the spots on you yeah okay and
then there's the hood spots like that
you got to go to a and uh
a r what
don't know
barbecue
for sure
you know i'm saying what else you need
to do it's a lot of stuff you gotta go
on bill street i'm just saying beale
street is like where like jazz and blues
and [ __ ] really had like a yeah like for
tours like tours that are going there to
be tourists go on tour [ __ ] yeah yeah go
go on
you know go to the river you know i'm
saying it's good to see stuff down there
but
don't don't just stay in bounds that's
all
okay what's out of bounds for people who
don't know where the [ __ ] shouldn't they
go if they're tourists
memphis turned the [ __ ] up is that about
where they shouldn't go it's about where
they need to go go so where did you go
wherever you decided to go go there and
go back to where you go back to your
airbnb or your hotel you hurt me
have you been able to link with any of
the uh any of the players on the
grizzlies throughout the years at all i
know you know obviously uh randolph has
always been involved in the hip-hop
scene out there i know he hasn't played
for a while but shout out to zebo but
now i ain't never really just
linked with no basketball players like
that
but i for sure
i for sure don't be into a lot of the
games though you got to get john moran
in the video somehow
shout out mike t my guy dj mike t i
think he's djing for the
yeah just got to get him to start
playing your [ __ ] and rotation while the
players are practicing he's always
supporting me
you know what's crazy is mike t is such
a memphis staple
that we worked for the same company
iheart
and they had took him off the radio to
put me on from l.a yeah
and uh shout out devon steele who was at
the station at the time but
i just didn't feel right about it
because i'm like bro i ain't even from
there and this is a legend like you know
what i'm saying like
it ended up working out where he you
know he he back on but shout out to mike
t man shout out to uh y'all don't want
he is supportive these are kind of it's
a lot of folks that just wait until
they just wait until you something the
show look like he was showing me a
little now it started like before
a lot of people wait wait until the
everybody like is it's the thing that is
it with anything yeah well artists
what causes you know people people want
to be [ __ ] super
in tune with like [ __ ] up [ __ ] when
it's like the popular thing to do but
it's like what are you doing when it's
not in the news you know what i'm saying
yeah hey we got to stop the interview
real quick man shout out to our sponsors
at mybookie now if you're into sports
like me you like to win money what are
we doing go to my bookie right now man
let's get in on some of this action
my bookie
go sign up get the double deposit bonus
that's what this means when you sign up
in my bookie right now
all right whatever money you would
deposit they're gonna match it they're
gonna double it for you up to a thousand
dollars but you gotta use the key word
the promo code
bootleg that's right use that promo code
bootleg when you sign up at mybookie
they're gonna double your deposit listen
march madness is coming up
my favorite time of the year to gamble
is march madness it is so much fun you
don't got to know a [ __ ] thing about
college basketball it is just [ __ ]
turnt up i love to go to
listen march madness that's really all
you need to know get your account before
then thank me later also nba action is
finally back throw down some futures who
do you think is going to win the mvp
joel embiid jokic devin booker a little
dark horse you know i'm saying shout out
to the suns uh you got to go to my
bookie though sign up get down right now
all right get double your money
double your deposit you put in a
thousand they're gonna match that give
you a whole another thousand to gamble
with mybookie.ag
use the promo code bootleg double your
deposit hey we gotta stop the podcast
man real quick appreciate y'all for
watching uh really mean mean it
subscribe like leave a comment even if
you're one of those [ __ ] who leaves
a comment you're always interrupting the
guest because it's my [ __ ] podcast i
don't know i like to talk too
anyway
hey shout out to odd socks man they've
been our sponsor from day one we go hard
for odd socks always man
literally go hard for my wife and i go
hard for odd socks
in different and same kinds of ways you
know what i'm saying sometimes i go hard
in odd socks
they do make boxers
you feel me
anyway um listen they got the ill
licenses they got the breaking bad they
got the wwe they got mountain dew they
got [ __ ] swedish fish [ __ ]
kool-aid
uh
pez you know
cheech and chong what are you into the
odd socks basics are the boys though
that's my favorite you know you get
yourself a nice pair of just basics
they're comfy it's like walking on
clouds all right so you can save 20 off
if you go to oddsoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev that's
one word bootleg kev all together
at checkout 20 off oddssocksofficial.com
go show some love and let's get back to
the interview
for sure um
besides your your mixtape coming out
what's the name of the project time is
money time is money i tell people time
is the most valuable currency for short
time i'm putting the money i agree one
thousand percent it's about what you do
with your time it's like
you're being productive you can be
making some money or making a way to get
to some money i'll be telling everybody
i'm like listen don't waste my [ __ ]
time it's the most disrespectful thing
you do to somebody is waste their time i
hate when people not
people playing with my time you playing
with my money that's a hundred percent
now or you just i mean you say you have
a family you got any kids i got no kids
no kids condoms
condoms
shout out to you hey keep that up how
old are you it's wonderful oh yeah yeah
don't have kids so you're like 30. don't
have kids too you got about five million
dollars
i wanna i wanna yeah i wanna have chats
i gotta you gonna have like five m's in
the bank
because you cuz you wanna like you wanna
kind of be i wanna have a counselor to
where when you born this is you already
took i don't wanna worry about it that
is a great that is a great uh plan we
just had t.k kirkland on and he was
saying
unless you got 25 000 in the bank you
shouldn't be [ __ ] not for sure you
shouldn't be thinking about it he's like
because one you broke as [ __ ] so if you
accidentally get a [ __ ] pregnant what
the [ __ ] you gonna do
cry
two if you if you're that broke
and you're worried about getting [ __ ]
you're gonna stay that broke yeah worry
about getting you some money before you
worry about getting laid
but not you're wasting your time
24 or 25 years old
yeah i mean no kids that's good
especially i mean being in your position
you probably you know
the dm's got to be crazy
the love with from the ladies
in the hometown got to be crazy
so have you had a
have you have you had like a girl that
are you in a relationship are you single
is it complicated i'm chilling you're
chilling okay that's fair okay i respect
that's such a great answer because that
can mean anything
so if someone's watching this they can't
even get mad because you're chilling you
can't be mad at me you know each other
yeah
chilling
um
anybody else outside of um the paper
round empire camp that you're [ __ ]
with in memphis who you maybe have a
relationship with or want to do some
music with
um
it's it's a lot of people i got a
relationship with yeah you know
for sure like people like take keith
i've been working on taking he's a beast
that's what we take he's just at first
started rapping like me and glock was
dealing with take you who was 14 and 15
wow
this is like way before yes we knew that
it's my dog yeah like
this is my dog and then he got a rz sign
nine clay
clays would be my engineer but clay a
dog rapping so that's my dog too so clay
take he so take keith to sign the sign
clay yeah he signed clay take you that's
hard bro people don't even realize he's
from memphis like i feel like we think
we we kind of we kind of discovered him
through black boy jb so it only makes
sense but like he's
he's on fire right now so take he win
big i feel
is um have you is he on the project at
all does he get any beats on the project
yeah nice
yeah that's good number six number six
yeah what is the one song tomorrow the
album's out no one's ever heard of your
music and they're like i'ma check your
project out but what's the one song you
want them to go to
i can't make this up
why that song because i ain't making
them nice that i need to automatically
know when they hear the rest of the
project everything i'm saying
real life is that the intro no it's like
a second i can't make this up yeah real
life [ __ ] yeah it's just like i just had
a feel like when that route i just rap
from the heart if i ain't if i don't
have enough if i ain't doing nothing
today i can't go to the studio without
from the rep about it
i gotta live and wrap it you gotta be
inspired i gotta be inspired
is it um
is it hard ever to be inspired because i
feel like sometimes you know not me i
told you like i'm
i think 24 7. i'm inspired by anything
you inspire me right now it's
interesting a nice fight
am i saying you're working anything
inspired me you can be whatever
so i always got something to think about
there's always you're always thinking
you read a lot or get in any books or do
you like dive down into youtube rabbit
holes
you know sometimes you i'll just be on
google google all the time i hear you're
weird i ain't never hear them like that
what does that mean let me google that
[ __ ] yeah the youtube rabbit holes are
serious though you'll be like start to
like be like oh what's this and then you
end up an hour and a half later
absolutely yeah and you're like now i
know so much about marine biology or oh
no i think i'm better with words
instead of images that makes sense i
mean you are a wordsmith yeah like
do you write your [ __ ] out or you
punch in freestyle punching i say what
they want my mind
stop right there
damn be like okay say something else
start right there sometime i keep going
it's just depending but i ain't writing
nothing
nothing ever you never were a writer
yeah i used to write
until
i started living so much
it's like i got too much to think about
too much to talk about i gotta stop
writing because i'm trying to cram too
much
more natural it's like a more natural
process for you yeah
yeah i feel like i don't know many
artists that write anymore
most people are still
i mean there's certain people there
right like we were talking we had black
boy jb up here and he said this new
album he did would take his first album
since like i don't know five years that
he actually wrote everything down
because he was
in that process of just punching in yeah
it's a different it's a different vibe
for sure i feel like you can get more
done faster when you punch in and you're
freestyle
i think i do it i don't even worry about
speed i'd be worried about the feeling i
get more of a feeling out when i
punch in because it's like lying for
lines like
he's more
emotional to what i'm saying
opposed to
writing it down and trying to come up
with a whole he put emotion in one whole
line like one whole sit up like nah i'm
gonna just
say i feel like i'm not cause anything
i'm saying
got something behind it i ain't just
rapping to be rapping you got a a lot of
jewelry here um
solid amount of ice you got what is the
wle whole lot of everything is that your
[ __ ] yeah man my gang risk my little
brother
lost his life uh like when he was young
he's always like oh we having a whole
lot of everything you know so so that's
the name of your company
so
are you actively on some ceo [ __ ] as
well and you're in your own type of you
know one type of way for sure
sign an artist or not yet not yet but
i'm definitely mentoring other artists
you know anybody want to know something
anybody want to learn something i'm open
i'm open to help you know what i'm
saying that's because when i do sign
somebody
to mine i want to do like
how my man dog did you know i'm saying i
want to take my time out to really put
myself to the side and focus on that
personal career because i don't want to
play with no better career
so
i'm a scientist artist for sure who's
been uh you i'm sure you've been in the
studio with a lot of artists yeah whose
creative process has impressed you the
most
baby
which baby are we talking about a little
bit okay okay
yeah i remember like a while back
right i was trying to get i was telling
i needed a feature from baby you know
saying i was in memphis this was like i
said it was before i was signed i was
doing everything myself yeah
i mean baby i think we had to sign a
lawyer or something and we had covered
mutual other people that i knew and i
called this girl like bro call baby
until i'm trying to do these songs right
she was like he got a show later blah
blah blah he said you gonna come up
there now imagine i'm in memphis like i
ain't hoping to get here real quick
where'd you have to go so
okay like nothing blew this flight
jumped on the flight went to the studio
played the song and he knocked the song
out so fast but he was hard like he
didn't play with it was hard and i'm
like
yeah
how many years ago was that
like two two and a half maybe it's crazy
because they always hear people say like
a little baby
i'm i think he's we've nev like like the
evol evolution of him as a rapper yeah
that we've like seen with our own eyes
over the last like four or five years
has been like something i don't think
we've ever seen yeah cause he went from
being like somebody who gunna used to
help you know gunna oh like he talks
about openly gonna help him learn how to
rap yeah so now he's like
top three in the world like the guy's a
[ __ ] monster yeah like j cole like
jacob that's another example of stan
staying hungry staying working staying
hungry staying humble yeah he's a humble
dude yeah and he's hungry like even
though he did this song years back he
still you know
that's my daddy cool is that what's your
biggest record that you've ever put out
as far as numbers wise
right now
if we speak now a lot
role models like going crazy for you
yeah
they like role model well before then i
had this song back in the day called uh
young trout [ __ ] like
ytn freestyle
they loved this song
super booked up so just it was like
another it was based like my
introduction right yeah what is it is it
um being an artist and kind of being
like somebody who's you know got us you
know kind of comes from the streets is
it a little like frustrating to like
have to like get on tick-tock and [ __ ]
because tick-tock
is kind of like
it's something you kind of have to do as
an artist now but it's also like kind of
goofy so you're like i don't know
he's like with t talking stuff like that
i'm open-minded to it but when i do it i
need to do it right so i'm gonna have to
find somebody who can you it's it's a
science to that [ __ ] yeah
yeah there's a way to there there's a
way to do it without being corny it's
just hard to figure out i ain't trying
to be corny because tic toc is a corny
ass app for sure but like if you could i
always tell artists like whatever you do
in your normal day-to-day life
just do it on tik-tok but have your song
in the background
like cooking like if you about yourself
yeah if you cook i know how to cook like
if you're like yo i know how to whip up
some crazy whatever the what's your best
dish
noodles
if you did it
if you did gourmet top ramen on your
tick tock but you got your record
playing in the background yeah that's
the type of [ __ ] people want to see yeah
and you ain't looking goofy you're just
building you're letting people in more
to your character you know what i mean
yeah what so we're talking ramen noodles
right oh yeah
i don't play with my noodles okay
because lemon peel
so what do we do okay so so are we all
right let's let's break this down are we
doing cup of noodles or the packet you
can go either way
okay so we got the brick and noodles
which flavor you start what's the base
beef chicken
chicken noodles so what from there fill
me in what are we doing chicken noodles
it's like you want to get fancy you can
work the stove but it's like sometime or
so i might be in the wrist i'll work the
microwave put them in the bowl put them
in the bowl
leave a little water in it yep
lemon pepper
garlic salt seasoning salt the chicken
packet hot sauce
and i got these little specialist seeds
and i use okay and i use cheese
sometimes i'll be putting cheese in
there too i don't say
people give me [ __ ] when i put cheese in
my ramen they say some white people [ __ ]
that cheese is smacking to eat his own
cheese sir yeah cheese and noodles ain't
bad no
no that sounds good
and like nobody elva people probably
like i don't know i'm saying it's doing
too much all right here trying somebody
tasted like you made me some more
can i get some more it's a great snatch
my bow gourmet meal
is there any sort of uh side hustles or
businesses that you want to end up
trying to get into or open up in the
future
yeah
maybe like a restaurant or something
like what where where hotel when i get
old i don't want to be seen you know i
folks want i want i want a hotel i want
to be making money all day wrong from
wrong
that's probably not too far off the trap
just jumping just you could probably get
especially if you get one of them uh
you probably start off with one of them
joints that [ __ ] be reading out and
selling their [ __ ] out of one in motels
you know what i'm saying them shit's
been booming
all day you drive one of them you know
them uh
them weekly hotels
if you see it says weeklies outside like
you know what kind of [ __ ] are
staying there they can't get qualified
for elise
they in there [ __ ] hoeing shooting up
lord knows with man because i know this
because my aunt my whole life always
lived in weeklies because she was
[ __ ] just a [ __ ] show of a human
being
and i'd go and see her yeah the weekly
spots some seagull sweets and all them
shits stay away my goodness oh yeah but
you could probably buy a spot like that
or so a little motel maybe you know what
i mean little
15 20 rooms
do like only fan special like we got the
only fans room [ __ ] you can come in
here or shoot your only fans content he
tried going
what we doing it sounded like you got it
meltdown
a little bit man um anything else going
on that you want to talk about man
that's coming up
rest of the year obviously the tapes by
this by the time this comes out the tape
is going to be out so just know the rest
of the year we going all the way up for
sure i got a lot of work i'm finna drop
a lot of projects whole team got a lot
of projects from the drop mushy about to
drop
glock dropping song like everybody
working the whole team is there going to
be uh
i know dolph had an insane work ethic
with and and was always working um i'm
assuming there's we're going to get some
unreleased off hopefully
i mean that goes without saying
anyone who's a fan of dolph knows how
much that dude he's not his fans forever
gonna be happy i'm that's i bro here i'm
telling you he's like a tupac work ethic
he loves his fans more than anybody so
for sure his fans gonna be happy it's a
beautiful
happening
we'll go go uh stream up your [ __ ] time
is money long live dolph is out too
compilation
and uh we're gonna have we're we're
gonna we gonna have this guy wrapped too
so that's gonna be a separate youtube
video
do it let's do it